Mary's rectangular poster is 36 inches
by 20 inches
Susan's rectangular poster is 26 inches
by 30 inches which poster has a larger
area and by how many square inches so
let's think about these so this is
Mary's poster Mary's poster is 36 inches
by 20 inches so it's 36 inches by 20
inches by 20 inches 20 inches so it
might look something like that
so the area the area is going to be 36
times 20 square inches 36 times 2 is 72
so 36 times 20 is going to be 720 square
inches square inches now let's think
about Susan's situation so let's draw
Susan's poster
Susan's poster is 26 inches by 30 inches
so 26 inches by 30 inches by 30 inches
so Susan's poster might look something
like that
that's Susan's poster my best attempt to
draw a rectangle what's the area here
the area is 26 times 30 square inches
which is equal to let's actually
multiply this one out 26 times 30 so we
can immediately just throw it let's see
we could do 26 times 3 and essentially
add a 0 there so 3 times 6 is 18 3 times
2 is 6 plus 1 is 78 and actually I could
have probably done that in my head 3
times 20 is 60 plus 3 times 6 is 18 gets
to 78 this isn't 3 times 26 3 times 26
would be 78 30 times 26 is 780 so it's
780 square inches so whose poster whose
which poster has a larger area
Susan's Susan's poster has a larger area
and by how many square inches well hers
is 780 square inches while Mary's is 720
square inches so it's by
60 square inches 780 - 720 would be 60